>> Okay. It's my great
pleasure to introduce
Shumo Chu from the
University of Washington.
He's a PhD student there.
He's doing very interesting
work combining,
using Automated Provers,
Interaction Provers for Reasoning
about Database Queries.
>> Thanks, Neil. Hello, everyone.
Today, I'm going to talk about
Automated Reasoning
of Database Queries.
This is joint work with Konstantin,
Chenglong, Daniel, Brendan,
Jared, Alvin, and Dan.
First to motivate us to
talk a little bit well.
So, this is a figure I
scrapped from Stack Overflow.
Well, it shows that SQL is the
second popular program languages.
The first one is JavaScript.
SQL is great because it actually has
a restricted abstraction that
enables powerful optimizations.
Well, during the 30 years of
database research resulting
many powerful optimizations,
which is based on semantic
equivalent of SQL rewrite.
However, there's lacking tools that
can actually reason
about SQL equivalences.
Well, I usually use a
self-driving car analogy.
It's embarrassing that we have
self-driving car right now,
we still don't have
an automated solver for SQL.
What exactly an automated
solver for SQL is?
Is that for any possible input,
I would want to check that whether
this Q one is equivalent to Q two.
Well, this has a series of
interesting applications.
For example, it can be used to verify
the correctness of a query rewrite.
So, you know that in
current landscape,
the database system
is used to develop by
big companies like Microsoft, IBM.
However, there is more right now,
like every open source community,
like every start-up company are
developing their own database system.
How to make sure those
database system are as
reliable as the ones developed
with big company is a big issue.
Second, it could be used for
a semantic caching layer
for data systems.
Third, it could be used for
automatic grading on the
data management assignment.
We need to scale the grading because
the limiting factor
is usually the human.
This is actually
a very challenging problem.
So, we have this theoretical
result dated back on 50 years ago.
Basically, he said that
checking the equivalence of
first others sentence over
finite model is undecidable.
While SQL is a super set
of first order sentences because
you can actually encode
first order sentencing in SQL.
This is directly
applies that to check
into SQL queries are undecidable.
Also, SQL has rich language features.
You might think SQL
just select from where,
actually there is way more.
For example, like in SQL,
you have aggregation and
grouping, like index,
you can specify index,
you can specify AT query constraints
like a primary key foreign keys,
and you can write to
correlate the subqueries.
Well, to solve this problem,
we basically have two observations.
First, from result, undecidability
doesn't mean there is no proof.
Actually, there is a development in
formal method called
Interactive Theorem Prover that
can actually validate
the mechanized proof.
The problem here is that,
how can we generate
these mechanized proof automatically
for a pair of SQL queries?
The second observation
is that we find that in
practice is a model of
an inequivalence SQL query
is usually not very large.
This is actually known
to the formal methods,
researchers as
a small world phenomenon,
and this is partially explains why
constraints nowadays
are extremely fast.
So why not just reduce a problem
and compel SQL to constraint
in a constraint solver
for model checking?
So based on these two observations,
we construct almost
automated solver for
SQL by combining interactive theorem
proving technique and
constraints solving technique.
So this is the overview
of the system.
So, essentially for two SQL queries,
we have two sort of
our execution pipeline in parallel.
The first is we compel
these two SQL queries into
propositions in
Interactive Theorem Prover.
Then, we developed a proof search
or we call it semidiscrete procedure
to generate proofs for this
specific set of SQL equivalences.
Well, if the Interactive
Theorem Prover is a proof,
they are definitely equal like
for any possible given input.
The second execution
pipeline in parallel
is we also compel SQL query
into software constraint.
So basically, we build
a model checker using rule set,
so for 80 programming language that
can find counter examples
for SQL queries.
So basically, a
counter example means that
a specific input such as
these two queries will evaluate
two different result and this is
clearly shows the equivalences.
So this is a high level picture
of this Automated SQL Solver.
So let's take a step back.
So the first problem
before even we are
talking about the
Automated SQL Reasoning,
the first thing we need to address is
actually the semantic for SQL.
At the beginning of this project,
we ask ourselves, what is SQL?
So if you ask people what is SQL,
is actually this NC
standardization document. So.
>> NC standardization document.
>> Yes. You can notice
that there is more
than like 1,700 pages
and really in English.
Well, I think most people will
agree that this is insufficient for
a rigorous SQL semantics and there
are many subtle issues there.
Okay. Maybe in the future,
we can use AI to generate
like a SQL language model
using the same,
but this is currently not
another current status.
Then, we look back to
the origin of SQL.
So if you take a very high level
point of view is SQL,
is actually not that complicated.
Well first, the data model
of SQL is relations.
So usually, in practical
database systems,
a relation is a collection of
tuples or a multi-site of tuples.
Then, a relation has a schema,
which is a set of attributes that
each tuple in this
relation must obey to.
Like super high level point of view,
a SQL query just a
transformation function
from a set of
interrelations to output,
which is also relation.
So that common underlying
abstract semantic for SQL
using database communities
of relational algebra.
So, I will take a brief introduction
to relational algebra.
So basically relational algebra,
the original variable
relational algebra is
defined over these five
operators over relations.
So, people used to
debating whether it should be
set semantic and back semantic.
Let's say, in practice,
let's just use a back
semantic, for example.
So, the first operator
is a Cartesian product.
So basically, it generate
all possible pairs of
the tuples from two relations.
The second, for example,
select star from course and student,
and the second operator
is a selection,
is basically apply a future
predicate over relation.
Third called projection.
It's transform a relation
from one form to another.
While in the output relation,
it has less in project
out some columns.
For example, if there
is a relation name has
a schema first name and last name,
you can do a projection only project
the first name, for example.
There's a force operator is union.
So here, we're talking about
back semantic unit here,
is basically, you just like
concatenated two relations together.
The last one is a like a difference.
So basically, I think in
mathematics, the cada monos.
It's like a stat is a different
operator over two backs.
People usually call these two,
the SQL only containing
the first four operators,
unions of conjunctive queries,
and this is actually like
a proving decidable,
but that seems to be
the end of story.
But why I'm still here?
So unfortunately,
there are like more operator
related in practice. So first.
Although by default,
it's like a SQL database assumes
that relation is a back,
but there is a explicit duplicate
elimination operator distinct,
or in relation to algebra,
they're called Delta, that sort
of convert them back to set.
So, in practice, the SQL is
running like a kind of mixed
bag and said semantics.
Also as a result,
a "Group By" which is grouping
a relation and you can
apply like aggregation
function over the grouping.
In addition, in practice,
people usually has
this Phi constraint.
For example, keys, foreign
keys, et cetera, et cetera.
So, I think the real
problem here is that
like there is no [inaudible] like
meta-theory for relational algebra, right?
So, if we're reasoning
about the semantic equivalence
of two SQL queries,
we sort needs such a meta-theory.
I mean, relational
algebra is nice but also
this is a leaking abstraction
in the sense that,
what is the semantic
of relational algebra?
So, there is an existing
work on this landscape.
For example, who actually have
a Coq Formalization of
relational algebra.
The basic idea is,
why not formalize relation as a list?
Right. That's normally how people
formalize like a programming
language semantic in Coq.
Then, two queries are
equivalent if they are
returning the same result for
all possible input relations
is also a list.
So basically, this is
a inductive argument.
Well, but the problem is
that you need to reason
about two lists are
equivalent, two permutations.
So, you can't see that the equivalent
to predicate here is
already pretty complicated,
is basically a fixed
point operation over
list over inductive structure.
So, I'll give a brief example here.
Right? So, think about
these two simple SQL queries.
The first one you union
two relations R and S,
and then apply a future predicate.
On the second one, you apply
a future predicate B over R and
S first and then union them.
These two queries clarity
should be the same.
So, think about if you are using
a model relational to the list.
So basically, you need to
do a lot of inductions.
So, like normally people do is
first do a induction on R and then do
an induction on S. This is kind of
a less inductions and for
the equivalent to predicates,
there's another induction
on the output relation.
So, this is known to be
a super hard problem
even in the programming language
and formal math research.
So, using this a relation
at least semantics,
you can prove some
simple SQL rewrite.
So, actually for query like
item potent of selection,
like the author used like 40 lines of
Coq code to prove
this very simple SQL rewrite.
Also, due to the
complexity of the proof,
very limited rewrite has been
proven under this semantic.
So, this is clearly not going
anywhere like if you want
to develop an automated
reasoning system for SQL.
So here, we come up
with different idea.
Well, the core of our idea is,
so why not model relation
just a function?
Because here, we only
care about the equivalence
of two SQL queries.
Unlike the previous work is that we
actually need to extract a system.
The idea here is that we model
relation as a function
from a tuple to,
let's say, a larger number.
I will claim this is really is like
how a relation or multiset should
be modeled mathematically.
Then, we model predicates as
a function from a tuple to
either zero or one, right?
And then this SQL query could
be modeled by a Select,
apply the future predicate
to the relation could be
modeled by the multiplication of
the evaluation result of
the predicate and times
the original multiplicity,
all numbers from appearance of
this tuple in this relation.
Then, union like
back semantic union is
simply the addition of
these multiplicities.
>> Is joining natural join
looks like you're duplicating
tuples in this third
formula right here,
mapping [inaudible] them correctly.
>> It's a Cartesian product.
There is no joint here,
right? The third one.
>> Okay. So, if it's
a Cartesian product,
then don't you end up with
two copies of the tuple in
the Select star from R?
I don't clearly understand
the function but-
>> So basically, the
predicate evaluate to
either zero or one, right?
So let's say this- try to
model the output relation.
>> What does it mean to
a Cartesian product of a function?
>> I mean, it's not a Cartesian.
It's actually the- Sorry.
Yes. So, there's no Cart-
>> A notational problem here.
That's all. I'm not questioning-
>> It's just think of as
a function of multiplication
in natural numbers,
because this is a natural number
and this is a natural number.
So, we are talking
about how to define
a symbolic function
of this SQL query.
>> So, the result is going to be
a binary relation over [inaudible]
>> That is a multiplication.
It's multiplication.
>> Oh! It is multiplication.
>> Just two numbers added.
>> Sorry. I have written the same
way as the same symbol, right?
>> Yes. I should make
a better deviation.
>> Does that make sense?
>> Yes.
>> Well, you can see that
by reasoning relations of
function for these two SQL queries,
if we would try to encode
these two relations this way,
like the proving the equivalent
is super simple.
So, it's just the distributivity
of multiplication.
I would argue that this way of
encoding relations of function
or brains of algebraic reasoning
to the actual, like a SQL query.
So for example, if you
want to prove this in Coq,
because you can prove
the distributivity of
natural numbers and then just using the
[inaudible] and code it all, right.
I will show later,
you actually don't need to
reason about in terms
of natural numbers.
There's even simpler way
of doing such reasoning.
>> Do you make use of
the functions of finite?
So, instead of valid formulas
of the finite structure,
follows that a valid finite
structures is not recursive.
>> That's a really good question.
>> That was the starting
point with proof.
But here, at least on the surface,
you don't mention whether
it's finery or infinite.
>> You mean the function?
>> The function. So, you want to
prove a theorem over
all finite structures.
If you are saying in
theoretical database,
but you approve the theorem is over,
all structures, finite or infinite.
>> Yes.
>> Then you are saying
a personal case [inaudible].
Are they interesting equivalences
that are true before
the final structures?
>> Yes. There is. But
it's a super adversarial.
Example, it's a discipline.
Basically, you can incur some super
weird that [inaudible] query to,
like only equivalent under
finite structure but
not like a criminate.
>> This approach will prove it.
>> So, it's a little bit
tricky here because,
as you can say, with the
function didn't assume anything,
given us some finiteness.
So like if you're talking
about function- So basically,
if you think of a like- so first,
finite relations, you can
still encode a finite.
You can sill represent a finite
relation using such a function.
It just like a- for example
if I have a database
with a single tuple,
the output is functioning
as a single tuple,
for anything else, it's zero, right?
So, you can still encode that.
So in that sense, this semantics
do apply to finite as well, right?
But there's another level of
[inaudible] , the tuple itself,
the domain of this function
might be infinite because if for
example you can have a
database stressed So,
that seems to have to be DOD anyway.
>> The function would only
be infinite worse, but okay.
>> Yes. So, I mean,
maybe we can talk more offline
to make this more specific.
So, it's this kind of algebraic
reasoning looks good so far.
However, there are two problems
of using this approach.
So, I think first problem
is a projection.
Let's take an example on
this simple database query.
Let's project out to the first name
from the layman relation,
it has two attribute.
For example, in
this concrete example.
Like let's say, it takes
these concrete inputs,
then that's a result of this query.
So, if you think about the
interrelation, it's basically said,
if the tuple is Michael Shulman
the multiples it returns one,
Michael Jordan returns
one, et cetera,
and for anything else,
it returns to zero.
So, the encoding of
this SQL query is really like how
can we encoding the output
relation using the input relation.
So, here for selection,
the schema action changes.
Then, what do you end
up with is basically,
we need a sort of
operator or operations
that add up all the multiple
facilities of the tuples
from the original relation with
the same value only on the first.
How can we do that?
Well, a naive idea is why not
just define a summation function.
So, we do a summation
of over all possible tuples of
the original relation name.
So, we just add up
all the multiple states
that have same first name.
So, basically this is a representation
of the equality predicate,
it will be event to
either zero or one.
The issue of this approaches,
first, we need to define,
what is the summation?
At the first time.
Like this gentleman mentioned
their summation usually can
only be defined in like
a finite structure.
How can we define a finite
over infinite structure?
I mean, sure we can go
back to the induction
again but this will kind
of a defeat our purpose.
Also, if we need to reason about
this summation like abstractly,
then, we sort of need to define.
Define an interpretation
of the summation.
So, this is first problem of using
this relation as a function,
way of doing algebraic reasoning.
So, any questions here?
Second problem we are facing
is a duplicate elimination.
So, basically, how can we
converts bags relations to sets?
So, a possible proposal here is
that we can define step function.
So, basically, we can
define step function applied
to a natural number for zero,
it's zero, and for
anything else, it's one.
Again, if we define this again,
it becomes an inductive
definition if we
want to reason about this formally
and it's kind of getting back
to inductive proof again.
So, the first attack
or the first solution we
have to this problem is
that we try to use
a different encoding.
So basically, we use a
homotopy type theory,
try to model homotopy type
instead of natural number.
Basically, we just read
the abstract reasoning of
the type, the type equivalences.
So, we don't want to reason about
the natural number inductively.
This is actually very nice
because we actually use
a dependent pair type,
the stamp type to
represent the summation.
It just become a type construction
and we also use a squash type
to represent the duplicate,
the elimination.
So, another bonus we
get here is that,
because in homotopy type theory,
it unifies type and propositions.
So, if we want to prove two
squash type are the same type.
It's just to prove the
equivalence of two propositions,
and we can actually
use a deductive proof.
So, I wouldn't go too deep here,
but this is just like
a high level idea.
By using this approach,
we have been able to prove a wide
range of database query rewrite.
So, one example we actually prove
is this famous magic set rewrite
that deals with that sort of
a very powerful optimization
that makes an easy query,
especially queries with
aggregation much faster.
It can be decomposed
into these three transformations
using semi-joints,
and we can prove all of them
using these new construction.
The names of prove is usually
less than 30 lines of code.
So, this is our first step.
So, the first step, formal
semantic for SQL queries.
So, before I move to the
[inaudible] , any questions?
Then we sort of ask the question,
like can we do better?
So, because sometimes homotopy types
theory is really nice,
but first the interactive to
improve our support for
homotopy types theory
is not quite there yet.
Also, one big problem here,
is that we still need
to manual proof.
Write the proof to
show that those two homotopy
types are the same.
So, can we fully
automate this process?
So, this is where
our second word come up.
So, the basic idea is that,
the foundations we need to prove
these equivalences is
actually quite small.
So, can we extract
a very minimal set of axioms?
That's very simple and
only using equations
but can prove all the curve
equivalences I've shown you before.
So basically, that's why we adopt
this as semi-rare approach.
So, our first step,
like I showed before,
our first observation is that
a projection actually
requires the summation.
So, the solution here is that,
we need a infinitely summation
operator defined abstractly.
The second idea here,
is that we need to
extend the summary with
the a duplicate elimination operator
or distinct operator.
The solution here is that,
we sort of add these native
construct of a squash operator.
So, it define as,
if the squash of zero is zero,
and squash of anything else is one.
Right. Also for
these non-monotone operator.
For example except, nor exists.
We need a not operator.
Here, we define not zero is one
and not anything else is zero.
Then, we can formally define
unbounded-semiring of the structure,
kind of a extension to
the classical commutative semiring.
So you can see here,
the first five operators
are other standard operators in
commutative semiring and
with three additions;
the squash, the nod,
and the summation.
The challenge here is that,
how can we sort of interpret
or model the semantic of
this three new operators.
So for those are interested,
the full list of axioms
are shown in the paper,
it's only less than 10 axioms.
I will just show you one example.
Here. The new summation algebra
seems very interesting.
How can we do axiomization
of this summation operator.
So, basically we find that
the summation operator can
be totally defined using
four minimal axioms.
The first axiom is
the distributivity.
This is intuitively true in
mathematical summations.
You can distribute
summation over a plus.
Also, is the commutativity
and you can commute,
you can sort of exchange
the order of two summations.
Third is associativity.
It basically said you
can't sort of push
the multiplication
into the summation.
Third is how summation
interact with a squash.
You basically can because
after the squash,
this become either zero,
this become a binary anyway
because it's either zero or one,
then you can push the squash
within the summation.
So this is the example of
the axiomization of summation.
So any addition as
I mentioned before,
we also need a- Yes, I mean,
before I moved to that,
any questions involving
this approach in general.
>> What are the major properties
of the axiomizations?
Is it adequate for-
What are the major properties
of the axiomization?
They're sound.
They capture zone.
>> That's a good question.
So, we only know yet.
I think that that's
an open question by
the- like we start with
uses. We haven't find it.
In practice, we prove a nice
number of database rewrite.
We haven't find a rewrite
that cannot be proven
using this approach.
I think of cour- I think
in high level of course,
if you abstract out something,
there might be something
you cannot prove about.
That's seems not the case at least
for interval using to prove database,
like a database equivalencies.
>> You used them as
directed rewriting?
>> Sorry?
>> Can you use them in the
in a single direction?
>> Yes.
>> It seemed to be left to right,
or actually, makes it privatize.
>> Yes. This is actually- That's
a pretty- That's
a really nice observation.
This is actually how we come up
with some ITZ and procedure.
It's kinda of do sort
of normalization.
Yes, doing sort of
normalization using
a single direction rewrite.
At the end, we still need to,
for example, do a permutation
over the summation variable.
Like it's not a conical form.
We still need to check the
like the isomorphism of- yes.
It's from the normal form
but not a canonical form.
>> When you're permuted into
equivalence of classes.
>> So, we still submitting
the equivalent classes, obviously.
So, this is a very high
level idea of this.
So, abstract reasoning of or symbolic
reasoning of a sigma [inaudible].
They are actually more working
those directled database.
For decode this FAQ,
they tried to use
the same sort of approach
to reason about a matrix.
Matrix multiplication in
machine learning applications
as well. This is-.
>> [inaudible]
>> I seen Hong. This is the reason
of work [inaudible] professor and
being you know, like a buffalo.
>> Okay.
>> Yes. So, that's
an axiomization of sum.
In addition, we also want to address
the semantic equivalence of
database queries and they're
integrated constraints.
We also- another contribution of
this work is that we also come up
with a very nice axiomization
of the constraint.
Only using these semiring identities.
So for example, we can define
the key constraint purely
using this equation.
So, it's maybe a little
bit hard to read
but like in principle,
basically says,
if these two tuples, t and t prime,
agrees on k, which is a- k
is a key of the relation r,
then there are two things happens.
First, if they agree on k,
then these two tuples
must be the same.
Otherwise, this equation
does not hold.
The second if the [inaudible] k-
I mean sort of for any tuples
that with multiples,
it cannot have a multiplicity
bigger than one.
Otherwise, this equation
doesn't hold as well.
So this is sort of a constraint
both the uniqueness.
This is a single equation
that the constraint
of the uniqueness of the value
of k across all the relations.
Similarly, we could define
a foreign key constraint, similarly.
By using this approach,
the entire semantic of
the SQL including like
any integrated constraints,
basically becomes axioms over
these new use semirings,
and all of these axioms are
Identities which is equalities.
There is no existential quantifiers,
there is no implication,
whatsoever, right?
So let me show you
a concrete example which kind
of SQL equivalences
that's this new symmetry can prove.
So, this is a example from
a Sigma paper of the IBM
Starburst Query Optimizer.
So, you can see that
this query is indeed like hid
the every pinpoints of
the subtotal SQL semantic.
You can see the first query is
a subquery, and within the subquery,
there is a distinct which makes this
from this IP relation like
[inaudible] relation.
There is no distinct
in the outer query.
In the second query, there is
distinct in the second query.
So, and also we know that these
item number is a key of item.
It's really not super intuitive
to see why they are equivalent.
If you know, if you read the paper,
it actually, I mean, it
basically because since
this item number is
a key and a disjoint.
While only end up with a relation
with a like a unique tuples.
So, that's a- if
you encode these two SQL queries
using our approach.
So, we can see this is
a formula of Q1 and this
is a formula of Q2.
I will ignore the actual proof.
Basically, if you apply
the rewrite- applied
the u- semiring axioms like using
our semi decision algorithm.
So essentially, we can sort of
normalize the Q1 in this form.
It's basically, you applies
a key constraint to
make this- to extend
this squash operator and
do a bunch of associativity
commutativity rewrite.
Then, you can see that
after this transformation,
this Q1 become exactly
the same as Q2.
Well, the name of the variable
here doesn't matter.
It's just a binding,
right? So, this is- Yes?
So, I will skip the details
of algorithm here,
but in principle, after modeling
SQL using our new semantics,
we can generalize the checking Q1,
Q2 to basically two cases.
We first do a normalization.
It's basically like
the single direction
rewrite like this gentleman
mentioned before,
and then checking the SQL equivalence
becomes two known cases.
Firstly is that, for
the unions of conjunctive query
under set semantics,
it basically becomes
checking the Homomorphism,
and for unions of conjunctive
under bag semantic,
it becomes checking Isomorphism.
For the constraints, the way
we do here is similar
to the Chase algorithm known
in database community.
We actually extend
Chase to bag semantic,
because Chase usually can
only works in set semantics.
I mean, the so-called Chase
here is really just that apply
the XML validation of
the integrated constraint
we defined to
rewrite these algebraic
expressions, right?
So, this is the approach
we developed for proving
equivalences of
SQL queries automatically.
I should mention here although
this semi decision
procedure is found.
Although it's not incomplete,
it actually works beyond
the unions of conjunctive queries.
It just for the scope.
For the SQL queries beyond this scope
is possible to run forever, right?
So, before I move on to the next
section is there any questions?
The next question we're
going to ask is that,
like I said before, this procedure
is sound but incomplete.
Then, what about
inequivalent SQL queries?
That's where our center
contribution is, which is,
we build a model checker for
finding counter examples of
equivalent SQL queries
using constraint solver.
Let me go back to
the system architecture,
you can see this is
the other parts of this is tool.
Well, I can more specific
need for a set of
database queries for a pair of
database queries, Q1 and Q2.
We solve using Rosette to develop
a symbolic executor of them and
compel them to Z3 constraint.
So, hopefully, these three
we'll find a counter-example.
To make the solver more efficient,
we also do like a increment,
like increase the model size from
the smallest to the largest.
I think the interesting
question here is that,
how can we encode SQL
using constraints solver?
In fact, we didn't encode
the SQL directly using
constraint solver but
we're actually using
the solver hidden language
called Rosette.
It's basically a record layer on
top of these three and
the encoding works like that.
For a SQL queries we
encode a tuple as a list.
A tuple is just a list of
integers and we encode
a relation as a tuple tagged
with multiplicity, right?
Let's do using these kind of a
relation as the function idea.
You'd just like encode,
so for example, our relation
is the list of a pair.
The first element of
the pair is a tuple,
like a defined before and
the second element of the pair is
an integer which represents
the multiplicity or
number of occurrence.
A SQL query is basically
encoding as a constraint
over symbolic values.
So, essentially, the integer here
is not a like a concrete integer
because it's kind of
a constraint solver,
basically like, work
as a reverse way.
It's like try to find what
the concrete assignment of
symbolic variable is, right?
Of course, we did
a few performance optimizations.
For example, in
this constraint solver,
we need to basically draw nine of
the concrete evaluation of
the symbolic evaluation.
So basically, we try to
maximize the concrete evaluation
and minimize the symbolic evaluation.
Sort of intuitively it's as
well like a decrease the size
of constraint the Rosette sent to Z3.
Also, we develop a few like
a symmetry breaking techniques.
So, there are like more things
I can talk about but
this briefly idea how these
symbolic evaluation of SQL works.
So, before I talk
about the evaluation,
let's actually look at
online demo, right?
So this a front end we
developed for Cosette.
You can see here that if you
can specify schema and a table,
defined based on the schema and
essentially two SQL queries and in
the end verify these two SQL query
are equivalent or not, right?
So here, the first query
is that it contains like
a correlated subquery and
the second query basically
contains a group by array.
So, like, is this
two SQL queries equivalent?
Well, this actually used
to considered equivalent
and KMW actually published a paper
in a top database journal,
like in 82 that
claimed that TDF discovered
new semantic equivalent SQL rewrite.
But unfortunately,
after three year later,
people find there's
a bug of this query.
So, if you use,
well, of course the demo is broken.
I don't have WiFi here, yes.
So, I mean, I can provide
the link of [inaudible]
>> The demo. Six.
>> I mean, you can
try the demo online.
It's a public available, right?
So for this, let me switch back.
So if you actually run this demo,
Cosette will return a counter
example within three seconds.
So, the tricky case here is
basically, the second query,
ignore the cases when the you do
the group by the group is empty and
the first query consider
in that case, right?
Also the counter example we find
using Cosette is pretty small.
Then, let's talk about
the Evaluation here.
We evaluate Cosette using
four real-world data sets.
The first is Bug, is basing
three real-world optimizer bug
we find from a bug reports online.
Second is XData,
which is occurring in
mutant pairs collect from
a test generation framework.
The third is the Exams.
This is a set of questions
from the undergraduate data
management class you should have.
Believe me, a lot of
them are pretty tricky
and the average GPA
of the undergraduate
for this class is not very high.
The fourth is the Rules,
we collect 68 query
rewrite rules from
both database literature basing
the 20 years of Sigma papers
and around 40 real-world
rewrite rules
from open-sourced optimizer
generated called Apache Cosette.
The first three categories contains
Unequal SQLs queries and
the last two categories contain
Equivalent SQLs queries.
So, first for the
Equivalent SQL queries.
Cosette can automatically find
counter example for all of them.
So, we can see here is the
solving time is pretty efficient.
It's usually last than 10 seconds.
For the Equivalent SQLs queries,
they are more tricky.
So, for the query
rewrite rules from a database
literature and the optimizer,
there is total 68.
We can automatically
decide 62 of them,
and every time it's
less than 20 seconds.
There is a six ones, it ran out time.
About we find that you can
still use our tool to write
your own name proof to prove them.
For Exams, we can prove
three out of four.
So, those Equivalent SQLs queries
that need to be manually proved,
are all beyond the scope
of SQL, of course.
So, what is to mention is that
for the Equivalent SQLs queries,
the proof we find is
usually pretty small.
For example, it takes
400 lines of coding.
A previous approach,
there is one example only
takes 15 lines of proving in Cosette.
The average proof size is roughly
about 20 to 30 lines of code.
Right. So, yes. Any question
for Evaluation?
>> So, when you prove
the Rules Equivalent,
can you start for optimization
[inaudible] optimizer?
>> So, the interface
we currently have
is to prove two SQL queries.
We would do that extract
two SQL queries.
The real optimizer that we are in
are usually in terms of career paths.
It's actually very easy to
write [inaudible] using SQL.
>> So, would you either use
it for as a test [inaudible]?
>> This are all
possible applications.
As at currently, we are
using Cosette ideas.
We actually tried to help
them with the testing.
So, for example, Cosette
has an input SQL query.
That's our query one and after [inaudible]
they becomes a cruise up there.
So, they have a reverse tool
that can reverse the
cruise plant back to SQL.
Then basically, it's like
a translate validation, right.
So, the real word
intended here is that,
every database internal has
its own form for commanding
cruise, et cetera,
and this is the most
practical usage right
now and you can imagine
more advanced applications.
So, like I showed before,
we develop a full stack of Cosette
including those solver core,
web service online demo,
and automated grader.
This automated grading tool
is deploying you like
a two database management
classes since last year
and this work has won
a signal best demo and
happens to be the top one
training record project
in GitHub and my joke is that,
if you want to make
a top one training GitHub project,
you need to use
a less popular language.
So, in conclusion,
I present Cosette as
the first practical SQL solver.
Cosette is based on
a new axiomatic semantics for SQL.
We implemented
semi-decision procedure
for unions of conjunctive queries
and they're both set in
bag semantics with
integrated constraint and
the core idea of
this architecture of Cosette is,
we actually integrate
both interactive theorem
proving and constraints solving,
to solve these really hard problem.
In addition, I believe
that Automated reasoning
brought by formal methods
plus dummy specific semantic.
The world needs more reliable
and more optimize future
of the data systems. Yes.
>> So, for the assignment grading,
what is this task that
the students are actually solving,
that this is checking them?
>> Sorry?
>> What is the task that
the students are solving?
Are they given one of the queries
and they try to run
it at other queries?
>> Given the English description,
write a database query.
So, then we test
the student answer against
the standard answer, right?
>> Okay.
>> I mean, we find that the
automated grader actually can find
tricky cases that the TA for example,
cannot find or TA or
graduate student cannot find,
but there is downside. At
end of day, for the grading,
you need to give partial credit
and we still working on how to
give partial credit for student
for the unequal and
equal SQL queries.
That would be a pretty interesting
research topic as well.
>> Have you consider
the case that sometimes,
the equivalence is dead?
>> Well, then they are not
universally equivalent, right.
>> So, why can't it be?
>> Can you give an example?
>> Example is how
the truncates depends on
the actual data to decide if
they are equivalents or not.
>> So, I will say, it's
a different equivalent criteria.
I think one way to
address this problem is
that you have a way to let the user
express these sort of data semantic
formally and then I think
it's possible that we
extend to that work
to handle such cases.
In fact, we do know
a more general data semantic.
For example, there is work from
Edenburg behave like
a conditional functional dependency.
I think it's interesting
to see, can we express it?
But, on the other hand
practically speaking,
in the real world SQL databases,
there is no way for the user
to specify such kind
of data semantics.